donald trump has been acquitted
uh by the senate uh 43 not guilty 57
guilded he needed
to reach 67 guilty
two-thirds of the senate or just over to
uh to get that guilty verdict through so
he has been acquitted our correspondent
in washington
is adam parsons i mean this is no
surprise adam but
seven republicans did vote against
president trump yeah
probably the higher end of expectations
uh ted cruz actually this morning
republican senator saying that he
thought it would be somewhere between 53
and 57. including uh bill cassidy and
mitt romney uh notable figures voting
against the former president but no
not enough and frankly nowhere near
enough to get
him convicted
that's uh the pro-tempo president there
just going through the results
the fact is that now donald trump has
not
just been the first president to be
uh accused twice in an impeachment trial
he's now the first person
to be acquitted twice and he will
consider this to be
an exoneration of him his reputation and
also i
think he will probably be emboldened by
this and say that this
actually justifies all of the claims he
made that meant that he was on
he was legally sounding doing them look
he's lost by 57-43
but he will portray this as a victory
over
uh the establishment who have tried once
again
uh to get him and i think in the
democrat side they will look and say
well they got a number
of republican senators joining this